yeah welcome to this video playing snake
eye from Sweden yeah baby let's go for
this check line D for him
I think d4 is the move they play I
didn't cards recently played this was
Bishop d3 it wasn't so bad
the idea is c3 Bishop C 2 and D form
quite similar to to the ruler person
anyway now it it's very it's not similar
to anything it's just just a bit strange
black is is very very far behind in
development looks quite quite dangerous
so this should f form yeah he's got 95
so just just developed it's probably
right
okay
just the tech d6 now
mm counter ticking on your form
is there some some straightforward
refutation of this I wouldn't be
surprised if there is one okay but don't
want to spend ages yeah it's still just
a week poor 96 even with the slow moves
like rookie one just in case if it takes
I'm not quite sure how he defends g6 now
maybe some sessom some tactical way to
do that I don't see one
yeah this is the passive way okay I can
I can just take this is one one good way
to play or just Queen d2
maybe it's just too windy to look do you
wanna piling up on the pole
should be 6m maybe Bishop e6 is an idea
it's a multitude of good news Bishop g5
is another one okay I know it it
releases pressure of the six but this
pin is also quite quite good because
this besides this weakness of the porn
d5 is also weak so here I'm yeah I can
actually go for this the typical
structure with the dominating night on
on d5 Marissa Bishop of course here the
bishop is it's not fatally bad on if I
third can you can get this in much worse
worse forms but it's still very good for
what
just making sure that all this is nicely
protected
you know but this is very very weakening
would be very surprising if this would
work for black I mean f4 now maybe he's
got a rupee form but still yeah it's
still good
then Quincy to intend a rook c8 but it
actually should win the Queen I don't
see how he saves the Queen chechik buddy
black resigns no this is just just
terrible position
the knight is completely dominating a
conference to take on b7 but I don't
think f4 is bad and thought he must play
here and then Queen c2 was my idea and
tending this the only move that doesn't
lose the Queen as I think queen of eight
then why this is really completely
dominating can can play something like
this if everything else fails it should
be excellent the Queen and oops oops I
didn't want to do that it's nice though
hey the Queen and and Knight are so so
nicely placed the structure that he went
for here was was really bad I think and
here thought 95 I don't I don't really
think that after 95 it's it's so serious
I mean white is certainly better but him
the night simply blocks this attack and
it's not so easy for white to make any
head
I probably play something like this year
to control c4 and then something like h3
controlling g4 Queen e2 group do you
want something like that and I'm still
better because of the porn but it's
nothing to to concrete it's just
comfortable but nothing out of the
ordinary
yeah thanks for watching